hey guys how's it going it's Justine and
today I'm extremely excited because I'm
giving away a homeboy
so you guys are new here you might not
know that I am obsessed with apple and I
love my home pod I've made so many
videos about it if you haven't seen
those they're somewhere here on the
internet that you can find for this
giveaway I'm teaming up with Goldie Blox
and she is hilarious she does all kinds
of really cool DIY videos for kids using
tech and science next month she has a
show coming out called robot runaway and
it's basically just what you would think
kids making robots and then two robots
face off on a runway I absolutely love
the concept and I'm so excited to see
the show but if you guys want to win the
home pod all you have to do is make sure
you subscribe to my channel to
goldieblox this channel and leave a
comment on this video I'll also put a
link in the description so you guys can
check out the video on the Goldie Blox
Channel talking about the giveaway
he's also throwing in one of these
really cool wrench necklaces which is
reflecting off of my lights right here
this is an official sign that you're a
part of the Goldie Blox squad so guess
what I think this means I'm a part of
the squad now anyway moving on to the a
sky so do you guys ask me questions and
I'm about to answer them I'm gonna put
my home pot off to the side this isn't
the one that you're winning because this
one's mine have you guys ever had
blackberry cucumber Lacroix lacrosse
lacrosse the cricket I still can't tell
if I like this flavor but I keep
drinking it and I keep buying it so I'm
pretty sure I like it what are your
thoughts on the fort night battle royale
from squids plays oh boy I've been
trying to avoid playing this game
because I knew that it is one of those
games that will suck me in and I'm not
gonna want to do anything else which is
fine if you don't have anything else to
do or if you do have things that you can
just put off and put to the side and
focus on playing video games which I
feel like unfortunately my time has been
very limited lately so if I want to play
video games and something else in my
life has to sacrifice like making videos
or trying to further my career of doing
whatever it is that I'm doing but I have
started playing and I've been really
really really enjoying it I've been
enjoying it and so is my dog
[Music]
oh I know what you're saying
oh he's playing with a controller oh but
don't worry he also can play with a
mouse too cyberpunk a 2098 wants to know
I'm gonna showcase my lavender s9 and oh
my goodness am I ever 5 here
does hopefully you can see it my lights
are very bright like it just it really
really looks good some of you guys might
be here because the title of this video
said s 9 vlog these are some clips that
I shot while I was in Hawaii I planned
on doing a bigger camera review video of
the s 9 but everyone at this point has
already done it so that hey I've got the
footage let's put it into another video
so here it is this is my vlog from
Hawaii all shot on ds9 look at this slog
[Music]
we are about to go on a hike but it's
basically a thousand steps all the way
up to the top of this mountain
it's the Koko Head crater trail Jen I
don't think you're on the right way
do you guys know what these shoes mean
you do a comment below well there it is
since the beginning to the end so they
started the trailer anyway let's see how
long it takes there's also a gun range
over there but as you can see here these
completely do not touch the ground it
just goes straight to the ground there's
holes and people are struggling normally
sweat a lot but this might be one of the
most exhausting things I've done in a
very long time almost there
so if you notice Jenna has passed me up
and she's already at the top hey Jen
barely cuz that we're gonna have to get
a helicopter I need to be droned down to
the bottom so he officially officially
officially made it to the top we are
here and we have to go back down you is
so awesome though definitely worth it
that's the end of this vlog because I
need to focus on walking down these
steps and not hurting myself
josh is asking what is one product that
you might want Apple to make that they
have yet to make for example the TV or
high-end headphones one of the things
that I love about Apple is they have a
tendency to find something wrong with
something and then fix it for example
the music industry they completely turn
the music industry all around years ago
when they announced the iPod and iTunes
then when they announced the iPhone did
it again with smartphones also with the
Apple watch granted SmartWatch
technology wasn't a new thing but I feel
like with the Apple watch it made it
something that everyone wanted and
everyone could have I know there's a ton
of other options but for me I have
absolutely loved his Apple watch and
I've used it pretty much almost every
day since I got one years ago so what is
that next thing or problem that Apple is
going to solve television is a very very
interesting sector because if you guys
haven't been reading in the news Apple
has been buying a lot of content
recently they open up a studio here in
Los Angeles and they have all kinds of
original programming coming out and then
couple of years so I'm very excited to
see what they do in that realm will they
come out with the television of their
own I don't know but that's definitely
something that I'm extremely excited for
another thing that I'm excited for that
I haven't seen any mention of recently
is the power mat they announced it at
WWDC and I have been waiting a fingers
crossed I'd say I was waiting patiently
but I'm not really that patient like I
want this thing now I want to be able to
charge my ear pods I want to be able to
charge my Apple watch and my phone at
the same time that was what the whole
intention of the power mat power air air
pod the air power I even answer your
question I don't know what your question
was Jacob wants to know where did I get
that retro Mac picture so this photo
here was my senior picture I have told
the story a few times so if you've heard
this pardon me while I burst into flames
thank you this thank you
putting me wallopers into anyway I am a
my mom tried it this entire computer
into the photo studio because I demanded
that this be my senior photo she's like
why don't you just get like a normal
picture I'm like no this is it this is
what I want my mom being amazing as she
is she let me do this and plug this
whole computer in for this photo session
so this is probably around 2001 I
graduate high school 2002 so I think the
photo was actually taken around 2001
then this past couple weeks I decided
that I wanted to recreate that picture
so that's where this came from and then
of course the meme that was ever so
popular the if you didn't love me when
then you don't deserve me whatever I
think it's a very silly meme but I
thought this was the perfect opportunity
to make this meme work in my favor or
not in my favor I'm not sure to be
decided hunter while these are a couple
of questions wants to know would you
ever surprise Jenna with a dog how do I
liked it into lab oh and what's my
favorite color
surprise Jenna with a dog I probably
would not do that because I think
surprising somebody with a dog is quite
possibly the worst thing that you could
ever do that person might not be ready
for it
it might not be the dog they had wanted
even though I'm sure if you gave them a
dog they would love it regardless but
that's really not a good idea I don't
think I would ever ever surprise Jenna
with the dog because if I did it
technically would be probably partially
my dog as well because if she can't
watch it I would be watching it and when
I can't watch them she would have both
Maddy and her dog Wow I don't know
there's too much that goes into that
don't think that you should ever
surprise somebody with a dog unless
they're ready because there's a huge
percentage of dogs that are given as
gifts and then they end up at shelters
so please do not surprise somebody with
a dog Nintendo lab oh yes I love it it's
so much fun I haven't got a chance to
build any other things as soon as I
posted this video but if you haven't
checked that out feel free to do so I'm
excited to build some more things from
the variety kit if you guys want me to
do a live stream maybe I'll do that
because I feel like making an entire
another video about building the items
I'm not sure if you'd want that but a
live stream could be fun I could chat
with you guys while I'm building Tyler
wants to know I'm gonna open a giant
Oreo Factory
I got so many incredible memes from you
guys from that Oreo video I was dying
just reading Twitter and you guys are
too much uh I love it thank you
Markus is asking me if I'm excited for
this year's iPhone yeah you better
believe it
hello I'm not an I in front of my name
and we've one last question here from
Jonathan asked me if I'm ever gonna come
to Canada again if I will go to
comic-con or the entertainment expo I
would love to I had a really great time
in Canada and if you're from Canada I
would like for you to leave a comment
below I don't know something cool about
Canada where should I visit where should
I go what should I do
I've only been there a few times I would
love to go up and visit you guys again
well thank you guys so much for watching
I hope you guys enjoyed this quick
little ask I J episode I love answering
your questions and it's always so much
fun to talk to you guys and don't forget
I am doing the home pod giveaway so be
sure to be subscribed to my channel too
goldieblox this channel leave a comment
below my dog is barking and also there's
a link in the description to check out
Goldie Blox this video talking about the
contest so with that being said I'm
gonna go and make sure my dad was
alright because he is barking up a storm
downstairs ah see guys later
I know he probably just wants to play
fort night again that's my dog
[Music]